uh we just mentioned the headline of
course that uh the supreme court has
been considering uh that appeal uh
relating to archie battersby and uh the
parents of twelve-year-old archie
battsby have lost uh the supreme court
uh bid to block the withdrawal of his
life sustaining treatment pending a
review
of his case by a un uh committee so the
supreme court has dismissed
that particular appeal by his family
which was attempting to prevent
the life support treatment uh from being
removed we will have further
reaction on that that tragic story that
has been uh going on for quite some time
of course archie about to be 12 year old
boy
who had been declared
brain stem
dead
by his doctors some weeks ago and his
family his mother holly dance in
particular had vociferously and fiercely
fought the decision by doctors to remove
life support treatment for him
and taken it to pretty much every single
possible court
that they could in recent weeks and each
turn resolutely
argued that they felt
uh he was in fact still there inside
despite the doctor's ruling um
and let's get reaction now from our
correspondent sadia chowdhury who's
outside the royal london hospital in uh
in east london and uh sadia this uh the
ruling the decision uh that uh uh that
archie's family and mother in particular
did not want to get
no and it has been a very tense morning
for archie's family we have uh spoken to
them throughout the morning and they
talked about how difficult this fight
has already been and this news will come
as a blow to them uh now that the
supreme court has rejected their appeal
um i'll i'll just go through what the
panel said uh so this is from the
supreme court which said that the panel
received this afternoon an application
to intervene by the secretary of state
for health and social care which it
grants it has considered the secretary
of state submission
in reaching its decision now that was
new we didn't know that earlier that the
secretary of state had himself
intervened
the panel it says is not persuaded that
there is an arguable case that the court
of appeal has erred and accordingly
refuses permission to appeal to this
court it says that the application of
course was for the stay to be extended
so that the united nations convention um
on the rights of persons with
disabilities could consider arch's case
it says that the panel is satisfied not
only that the court of appeal has not
heard in the sense mentioned above but
that it made the correct decision that
is the decision yesterday uh to not uh
allow an extension it reaches this view
it says and then it outlines a number of
reasons and it will come as a blow to
the family who had hoped that the
supreme court might take this matter uh
further for them and that any government
involvement would look at it
in a sense of
the importance of international law the
family argue that that that convention
um is binding on uk law but clearly here
the secretary of state has intervened to
say that it isn't um we did uh
speak to the family earlier we asked
them about how they felt and they said
that um
they
were hoping that
the supreme court can give them some
encouraging signs but this will be a
blow and we wait to see what their next
steps could be with the trust we know
have said that they were waiting for the
outcome of today's decision before they
proceed with withdrawing treatment
remember that stay had expired at midday
today
after which it is now uh permissible for
the
for the trust to start withdrawing
treatment uh we again we await to see
what the trust say they did say to us
that they will be releasing a statement
shortly
and sadia not not to sort of labor the
point but just just remind us all uh
what remaining steps there are if any
for archie's family
well the supreme court is the uk's
highest appeals court so at least on a
domestic level there doesn't appear to
be anywhere further to go um the the
supreme court being the highest appeals
court for civil cases
internationally there was there were
always several options there was the
european court but also the united
nations and the family had chosen to go
to the united nations specifically
because of this
right that the united nations offers
under that convention for the rights of
persons with disabilities
and they looked specifically articles 10
and 12 articles 10 was to the right to
life and article 12 is about equality
for disabled persons now archie's family
say that it's not about the level of
disability all disability should be
treated equal to everyone else and the
fact that
doctors here are saying his prospects
are bleak they say is irrelevant because
if somebody is disabled they should be
given every chance
to survive and every medical
intervention that they require
the trust's argument is that his
prospects are so bleak actually they've
outlined in several court cases the kind
of medical intervention that is needed
to sustain life they talked about things
like um his blood pressure has to be
monitored and regulated his body
temperature they say needs to be
monitored they've even told us about the
intricacies of having to administer
artificial teardrops every four hours
and they say that every part of his
living is being done artificially and
therefore it is in his best interest
to withdraw treatment but you know we
will wait and see what the trust says
they are of course now under a court
order to withdraw that treatment and
they can do that at any point after
midday today
they've always said that they will do it
in discussion with the family
and but the family say that they will
carry on fighting they've always said
that right to the end to explore every
viable option
to give archie more time to recover
and we await to see what they will say
thanks so much uh for that update